it's time for the lawn gene conosco a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought to you every
monday wednesday and fridays a
presentation of the lawn gene but nor
watch company maker of lon gene the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lon gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the lawn
gene Kranz code from the CBS television
news staff Larry lesser and lucha fee
our distinguished guest for this evening
is Horace e Underwood chief official
interpreter for the United Nations
command at the penguin John truce talks
mr. Underwood bond you rested the
responsibility during those frustrating
two years of negotiating of interpreting
to the North Korean communists when it
seemed to us that war and peace were
hanging by a single word would you mind
telling us how you became so proficient
in the Korean language well had a pretty
good start at if I was born there in
Korea my grandfather was a pioneer
missionary in Korea and my father was
missionary work and I've been in
missionary work myself I was in Korea in
1940 when were 41 when World War two
broke out was repatriated and joined the
Navy then then after World War Two I
went back to Korea and when the Korean
War came out why I came back on active
duty again right in Korea came by your
Korean proficiency naturally that's
right well I wonder if he'd mind telling
us how those sessions actually worked
out perhaps you describe a typical
session to us in those pan when John
true stents well the usual starting our
was eleven o'clock in the morning we'd
go up there the delegates in our side
would walk in on how they timed it but
both sides used to walk in almost on the
dot with each other Admiral joy and
later General Harrison would make
whatever statement they had to make and
I would get up and translate it into
Korean a army officer would get up
another army officer we get up and
translated into Chinese and general nam
ille would give his answer their
interpreters would get up and put it
back into English and in a Chinese again
so everything had to
go through quite a number of steps well
mr. Underwood we met before as a matter
of fact as a member of outside the tents
at penland jump that year and a half or
so that I was there while you were in
there did you negotiators feel any
particular pressures from the outside
say American public opinion or communist
propaganda well I don't think we were
directly affected by the communist
propaganda except insofar as they're
delaying tactics or the pressure of
events back home would sometimes put
pressure on us what kind of pressure
well sometimes we felt almost as though
we were on two fronts we had to maintain
our position not only to the Communists
but to the American public at home and I
feel that quite often for whatever
reason the American public didn't
understand what the issues of the moment
were they understood the overall issue
but not the issue of the moment and they
would become impatient I think Americans
pride themselves on getting things done
but in negotiations that impatience can
be a handicap sometimes we were actually
up there doing the political campaigns
in this country did you feel any
pressure of domestic politics on those
negotiations well I don't think there
was much direct pressure of that kind at
all we all felt that there might be some
new policy overall policy as a new
administration got in but we do have no
idea what it would be your instructions
remain the same but tell me mr.
Underwood I understand that you also
screened those North Korea and a
prisoners of war that took part in the
operation little switch which finally
led to the breaking of the ice around
the the truth can you tell us that
whether any political pressures brought
against those North Koreans as charged
by the communist radio no there were no
pressures from the outside at all among
themselves I suppose the violently
pro-communist and the violently
anti-communists as I guess Lou knows he
was down there sometimes broke into
fights of one kind or another but there
was no outside pressure on them at all
it was strictly their own choice well
how would you explain the Akagi dole
riots well I think it's been made public
knowledge that the Communists sent
agents down to be captured and to be
sent into the prison
of war camps to create riots to
embarrass the UN Command well talking
about the prisoners of war right now we
have a situation where thousands upon
thousands of North Koreans have gone to
explanations and refused to go back to
North Korea what why is this well I
think it's a tremendous demonstration of
how hateful a communist regime can be
those are peasant people who stick by
the land ordinarily to the bitter end
and yet those thousands of people after
having lived under that communist rule
are willing to abandon their homes and
their families and everything to get out
from under it I think it's the one of
the greatest blows that communism has
had in all since its inception well on
the other hand now we have 300 or so
south koreans who refuse to come back to
our side including those 22 Americans in
the one Britain how do you explain that
I think that's quite easy also the
Communists captured I forget the last
figures but they captured something
around 80,000 i believe it was Korean
prisoners and that the Communists could
find only three hundred and some-odd
prisoners that they could indoctrinate
sufficiently to publicly say they would
not go home i think is an amazing
testimony of how much how hateful it is
to the people i mr. Underwood you were
in Korea during the Japanese domination
I gather well we know now that the South
Koreans don't lack for courage nor
inability to master modern techniques as
shown by their ability to pick up our
training programs so quickly can you
tell it tell me is there any difference
between excel Koreans now and the South
Koreans who are under the Japanese
domination psychologically no except
that they're free now under the Japanese
I don't think most people realize how
much the Japanese did suppress them
almost nobody could go to college in
Korea under the Japanese almost nobody
could get any kind of position of
responsibility or directorship or
anything else they were very heavily
suppressed and then when they got their
freedom they've had it started to have a
chance now to express themselves and
some people feel what they're doing it
almost too much but I think it's a
wonderful sign that after the 40 years
of japanese suppression they can still
come
out the way they had you think they're
feeling a real release of mental
energies yes sir they mr. Underwood
sometimes I think that Korea is a kind
of Poland of Asia since it's caught
between two great neighboring powers
Japan and China can you tell us which
one of these peoples the Korean dislike
the most the Japanese or other Chinese
well I think that probably emotionally
on the individual basis I imagine they
just like the Japanese more right now
when China's run by the communists they
are deathly afraid of and desperately
hate the communist regime so that right
now China is their greater and more
deadly enemy that's so well by the way
what is the official religion of Korea
are you were a Christian missionary
there naturally well there's no official
religion actually Christianity is
probably the strongest religion in
career at the present time only about
five percent of the people are
Christians but their masses the people
have no religion at all or just kind of
an atom ism and Spirit Worship sources
and witches and that sort of thing so
the Christianity has become the real
leader of the people Luke and testify
that I think most of the leaders in the
government are Christian trained if not
actually Christian men and i think the
imprint and the pressure the hope of the
Christian Church in Korea has been one
of the greatest salvations of the
country in his past trial would you say
that the Christian religion is actually
spreading in Korea oh yes is spreading
very rapidly they are eager for it well
what was the original motivation of our
missionaries in going to such a remote
place in the world mr. under which
probably heard stories from your own
father and grandfather well a basic
motivation of all Christian missionaries
of course is that they should go out
throughout the entire world to preach
the gospel my grandfather's particular
case he was planning to go to India and
was looking around just for a missionary
to send a career and violate all of a
sudden occurred to him that maybe he was
the one that should go to Korea so
that's his personal story but the
missionaries feel that the Christian
religion the benefits the
all spiritual benefits of Christianity
is something that should be taken to
everybody and in Korea especially it is
certainly shown that they are willing
and eager to get it well mr. Underwood
there were some tense moments in Korea I
believe our correspondent mr. Joffe was
there during the truce negotiations when
they were actually coming to a climax
and there were demonstrations outside of
the correspondence barracks of allelic I
had the tremendous demonstrations of
students out there well I wanted to ask
mr. Underwood whether he thought that
the white people could actually be
friends of the Asians or whether there
is a really a deep-rooted distrust of
all white men I can't speak for the rest
of Asia but i know that in korea white
men in general in America in particular
are their friends they they look to
America as their friend the four years
the only imperialism they knew was
Japanese Imperialism and the white
people were primarily the missionaries
out there who were bringing them
education and medicine and religion and
there is a deep well of friendship for
America in Korea do you think that's
really friendship or respect I think
it's both they they are very friendly to
Americans he gets to be almost at right
phrase sometimes but they speak of you
who have come 10,000 miles over the sea
to help us and they really mean it they
also have respect for our technique in
technology in progress well mr.
Underwood we know that's true of the
Korean people do you think it's the
Korean government trust the United
States that's a little different
proposition they are very grateful for
the help that we have given him Lou
other hand I think the root of some of
the present frictions between Korea and
America has been that they have been
unable to know just exactly where they
stood in respect to the United States
government shortly before the korean war
broke out the world was told that career
was going to be written off and then we
came to the health it's been a changing
proposition mr. Underwood as a final
question I asked you what do you think
are the chances of war and peace in
Korea now and in the future I don't
think there will be any final settlement
in Korea until the final east-west
tensions settle down they cannot solve
it just as a local matter I don't think
the war is going to break out again in
the immediate future but the overall
settlement is going to have to wait for
an overall east-west settlement and I
say you don't think Korea can be unified
until then what do you think it will
continue as a source of tension between
the area definitely there's going to be
continual friction along that border
whether it was the former 38 to the new
military demarcation line you've got the
two regimes face to face there in Korea
and there's no compromise between them
at the present time and you're going
back as a missionary I want to thank you
very much for being here tonight mr.
Underwood the opinions you've heard our
speakers expressed tonight have been
entirely their own the editorial board
for this edition of the lawn gene chrono
scope was Larry loser and lucha fee our
distinguished guest was Horace e
Underwood chief official interpreter for
the United Nations command at the pen
lunge on truce talks